[Music]
As of late 2018, multiple mainstream
news outlets have covered the topic of
witchcraft being on the rise in America.
Hail to the guardians of the Eastern
Washington.
It's estimated as many as a million
people identify as being a witch in the
US with 20% of that population to be in
New York. Um, what does this mean
exactly that you cast a binding spell on
the president?
So, we're here in Brooklyn where a group
of pagan witches have gathered to place
a hex on the newly confirmed Supreme
Court Justice Brett Kavanaaugh.
One article says that the witch
population has doubled in the decade as
millennials cast off Christianity. New
York Post says,
"So, why has witch popularity doubled?
Perhaps it's because millennials were
raised on Harry Potter. Or maybe it's
because of the rise in popularity of
yoga and meditation, researchers
suggest. Regardless, millennials have
embraced astrology and the supernatural,
even if they aren't quite sure why. In
fact, Stella Bugby, editor-inchief and
president of The Cut, told The Atlantic
that their horoscope content traffic
increased 150% from 2016 to 2017.
I tend to agree to the old saying, life
imitates art. It's not hard to see that
the masses follow pop culture trends
that appear on the American idols of
Hollywood. Even in my own life, when I
started searching for truth, I was drawn
to witchcraft. The Craft was one of my
favorite movies in high school, which
probably had a big influence on my
interest in Wikah. The movie is based on
four high school hotties that start
dabbling in the craft and make it look
like lots of fun, changing the color of
their eyes and hair, turning red lights
green, and levitating off the floor. Of
course, this is only one of hundreds of
movies and shows that glamorized
sorcery. Looking back now, I can see the
paganism seed was being planted all
throughout my life growing up. Cartoons
like He-Man
and the Masters of the Universe
and Captain Planet are laced with
components of magic, sorcery, and
calling upon the elements.
Fire,
wind, water,
HEART, GO PLANET.
Earth fire,
water, fire,
earth, air.
It's witch. Premiering Saturday, January
28th at 3:30, 2:30 Central on Disney
Channel.
[Music]
Will lead the way to what we can
control.
Fire
tonight.
We are We are We are
There's
[Music]
What do you think of the new song?
Tra of life.
Beware the tra.
[Applause]
[Music]
Only three others share this secret. Our
friends, the sorceress, man at arms, and
Orco.
It's no wonder that this last year's
Pagan Pride Fest held in Nashville had
an attendance of 1,51
practicing pagans, which was quite a
jump from the last year's attendance.
So, there's been shows in the past that
glamorize witchcraft, but there's also
been shows like Little House on the
Prairie, Highway to Heaven, Touched by
an Angel, and Seventh Heaven. So, it's
not like there's only one side being
pushed here. Well, which direction has
Hollywood gone since the 80s and '90s?
It seems that shows containing magic
have continually increased while
Christianity portrayed in movies and
shows have continually decreased or
worse blatantly mocked and ridiculed. So
is it really shocking that American
millennials are rejecting Christianity
while embracing the way of the witch?
Not really. Life imitates art.
So not only is the world being seduced
by sorcery, but also the Christian
church. There are major Christian
ministries today who are selling what
they call angel boards and they are a
Ouija board.
So, so just a rebranded Ouija board
and they call it an angel board where
you can talk to your angels. Typically,
New Age will say spirit guides, but the
terminology doesn't matter. It's all the
same thing. There are there are tarot
cards. They won't call them tarot cards.
They'll use the different names, but
there there are tarot cards that are
being sold through major Christian
industries right now. Those are just the
extremes. It's creeping in in more
subtle ways that as Steve said, it
absolutely is infiltrating our churches
and it's stealing our children.
Valerie Love is a self-professed
Christian witch, the author of 14 books,
all of which have four or five star
ratings on Amazon. The Bible clearly
condemns sorcery and witchcraft as a
sin, but Valerie tries to justify it to
her audience. I am Kaisi, divine midwife
of soul destiny Christian witch and the
author of 14 books on practical
spirituality. How you loving? I was
still I was prayerful. I was meditative
about what I am about to share with you.
How you loving?
We have the church ladies that come in.
You can't be no Christian and no witch.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. We got the
Christian witches. Like look,
we can be Christian Christians and
witches if we feel like it. WE CAN BE
ANYTHING WE WANT. AMEN. Let the church
say amen. Who is ready to move on to
bigger and better things as being a
Christian witch rather than can you be a
Christian and a witch? Can't be a
Christian and a witch. Can't be a
Christian and a witch. You can't be a
Christian and a witch. Stop it. Here's
the short answer. The short answer is
yes. That's the short answer. And why?
Because you can be any thing you want to
be. You can be anything. Look at my
words, people. You can be anything you
want to be. She's not alone in
professing to be a Christian witch,
either. Also, approximately 500,000 men
and women are members of the Order of
the Eastern Star. Just look at their
official logo. It's identical to the
pagan witchcraft symbol. You have an
inverted pentagram with the same exact
colors and the same exact positions.
Paganism and witchcraft seems to have
infiltrated America at its core. Even
the map of Washington DC is in the shape
of a pentagram. Disney is well known for
spreading their message of follow your
heart.
I have to try this my way. Maybe it's
time to start following your heart.
You can be anything you want to be.
And they're not even hiding the
witchcraft anymore. They're using the
identical language such as the Guardians
of the Watchtowers. But one of their
newest and probably the most blatant
glamorizing of witchcraft is the show
Descendants. Sure, these witches are
supposed to be the bad guys, but they're
also the ones that look the coolest and
the most fun. They're actually walking
around on a school campus talking about
how fun it is to be wicked. And just
look at the students. They look boring.
But whenever the witches come around,
things seem to light up and become
exciting. Can you see why so much of our
youth is gravitating towards witchcraft?
My favorite, if anyone knows, my
favorite is mouth.
So for Halloween, I'm going to be here.
Wicked ways beneath the skin. Let all
who taste it now join in.
And just look at the way Christianity is
portrayed in the media. They're either
really geeky and boring.
Daddy says dice are wicked. We just move
one space at a time. It's less fun that
way.
Completely annoying. There's going to be
a flatty
or worse against everything. Where are
we? This is Cohord Brian. Same year,
same time. But in this universe,
Christianity never existed, which means
the dark ages of scientific repression
never occurred. And thus, humanity is a
thousand years more advanced.
Can we honestly say that this shift has
happened organically with zero influence
by the media? I don't think so. Let's
just be honest here. Witchcraft is a
religion.
Witchcraft and its more modern
incarnation, Wikah, are pagan religions.
Can you even imagine what the ACLU would
do if every movie and TV show you've
ever seen that glamorize witchcraft was
actually glorifying God and
Christianity. Somewhere there's been a
shift where it's offensive to have a
cross or a Ten Commandments monument in
a public place, but it's completely
acceptable and unquestionable to promote
witchcraft to kids. There was a time
when Christians were looked at as
trustworthy and at worst a goody two
shoes. It's pretty ironic when groups
are marching in the streets talking
about tolerance and acceptance yet they
want you to tear down your crosses and
ten commandments
like just tolerance and love and
acceptance.
Isaiah 53:6 says, "All we like sheep
have gone astray. People have a
herd-like mentality and we like fitting
in with the majority. If a well-known
celebrity wears a product or endorses
it, suddenly everyone else wants that
product." And remember, as you're
watching these pictures, this is all
over shoes.
How many pairs of Air Jordans do you
have?
I have about nine pair of Air Jordans.
But it does not matter about those. It
matter about these right here.
This was the scene in Kansas City where
people were sprinting through the halls.
But that's nothing compared to the mall
in the Seattle area where people use
pepper spray to break up a crowd that
was pushing and shoving.
Being a Christian goes against the
grain. Jesus says, "Enter ye at the
straight gate. For wide is the gate, and
broad is the way that leadth to
destruction, and many there be which go
in there, because straight is the gate,
and narrow is the way which leadth unto
life, and few there be that find it." We
look to their behavior to figure out
what the best thing is. Cuz if they're
doing it, it's probably pretty good for
us.
Just followed along, started dancing,
joining in.
It's mental. It's crazy.
Absolutely crazy. It said the line's
here, so we got in the line.
Remember, these people are happy to do
all of these ridiculous things for no
other reason and because the person in
front of them is also doing.
These trends really shouldn't shock us
because they're signs of the times that
the Bible compares to the days of Noah
and Lot.
Apollo's been casting spells since he
got hooked on Harry Potter. What's more
shocking is that even the top 20 secular
shows regularly watched by Christians
include How to Get Away with Murder at
number three and Lucifer at number four.
These shows are full of darkness. It's a
show about homicide, sex, conspiracy,
and betrayal. And those are the tame
episodes. How to Get Away with Murder is
a breakaway hit here on ABC.
And First John 15-7 says, "God is light,
and in him is no darkness at all. If we
say we have fellowship with him and walk
in darkness, we lie and do not practice
the truth. But if we walk in the light
as he is in the light, we have
fellowship with one another. And the
blood of Jesus Christ, his son, cleanses
us from all sin. People are searching
for meaning in their life and are
gravitating towards witchcraft because
it promises spiritual power and is
glamorized by the mainstream media. In
these last days, we should be taking
special effort in reaching out to these
people and showing them what true
Christianity is all about. Let's help
the world see that these false
representations of Christians are wrong
by being shining lights in this dark
world. The reason I want to talk about
this topic is because I was impacted
personally by this. When I started
seeking truth, I went down the road of
witchcraft because uh the church kind of
turned me off and and Hollywood made
this stuff look cool. So, I can look
back now and see how the media really
does have an effect on the things that
you're into. It It makes things look
interesting. And so I want to expose
that with this LED and show why
witchcraft is on the rise in America.